[Music]  we have a big milestone coming for you  it's almost 15 years since your debut  album and in the club I mean isn't that  crazy TV this is amazing how fast the  time goes yeah it's cool I got um  because every day someone's birthday  songs music marks time so you know we  can have new music current like this why  I don't like to get in the mix there  like this hip hop is connected to youth  culture you gotta kind of let it rain  you gotta let new things happen now the  rapper who brought us that timeless  track is starring in his new film den of  thieves alongside co-star Gerard Butler  50 cent and Gerard told et they are  ready to collaborate in the studio this  guy he has some singing chops I need to  know did you know I fifties music before  you met him I said I could get I gotta  get something from him sample that I  could have a piece of his voice into a  record on stage of them somebody keeps  saying yeah yeah let's do I don't  believe it out  [Music]